jean michel bonsoir je ris mais le coeur
n'y est pas évidemment c'est ce que
géraldine soit pas là évidemment pas
réussi la prise juste avant d'arriver
j'ai failli ne pas faire des missions et
vous avez gratter un petit quelque chose
rapidement beach est comme ça un petit
hommage à francis pour géraldine voilà
on espère que cette chanson lui remettre
un petit peu de baume au coeur
allez ailleurs aussi
irène avait rien et voilà qu'aujourd'hui
elle a eu la gastro milieu de la nuit
géraldine vous pouvez me dire que c'est
vraiment traquera que je n'ai qu'à y
offrir des kilos de smecta de retenue
retenir je lève géraldine elle a dû
faire le tour des trois lettres du
quartier pour tous la retrouver des
rouleaux de papier donné par le dit qu
elle reste marraine même assis sur son
trône elle fait plus de bruit qu'une
fois par de trop bonne elle peut pas
dormir elle ne pas dormir
elle a dû faire tout autant des chiottes
pour être absent aujourd'hui elle a dû
faire toutes les chiottes de paris elle
banlieue aussi
j'ai rappelé aux devoirs sur la tête de
ma mère justin timberlake en cours moyen
des bureaux est ce que est ce que pour
une chose qu'il va falloir nous la
refaire après l'agression